[Music]
in bitchslap new Wow
I was just talking about it boom
submitted by Karina Karina Karina a
Mexican soap opera actor slapped a
reporter doing a red carpet interview
this slap is it this slap no it was it
was at this yeah yeah yeah I saw the
clip it was a woman that was getting
sexually harassed no no it was a dude
with one back hand up but way harder oh
[ __ ] because when I think of Mexican
soap opera I always think of really hot
Spanish women and men the men are very
hot they're very much okay just look at
them you're gonna be like oh jeez I'm
looking at both of them and they're both
very hot yeah it feels like a porno is
about to start but it never happened I
know right their news right compilation
of the Mexican weather girl oh yes every
time she turns around she turns around
like god that's my major Guinness it's
called a weather balloon
wow it's got a warm front
yeah male viewership spikes I really
like how in Latin channels there's no
shame in being horny it's not being real
or being real being real I like that we
can't hide the curves dude we can't hide
it but they raise their kids so
conservative let me tell you I you said
I used to watch sabado sabado gigante
every week bro even though I didn't know
what the [ __ ] that was sorry baby cell
though I thought you're talking about
Salvador Dali with a melty clock I mean
yeah [ __ ] with the multi car accident I
like that [ __ ] that turns a monster slow
this telenovela star name and what is
the water union here's like a really big
cactus collector he has very many
succulents
come to my backyard we have 3000
purposes picture every single rich Latin
millionaire that they live in like this
Hacienda that looks like the all Alamo
they have a horse stable thinking of
[ __ ] Pablo Escobar everyone but in
every novella that's true they actually
do have all that Hacienda right for some
reason they know where they were never
cut the button up that shirt past the
middle one gold chain or so because
these are my recreation clothes these
four lesions are suede he was on a red
carpet and you've been interviewed by
other report this reporter who works
with a program called Gordo he left like
at and so I know that shows the other
huge the skinny girl and the fat guy so
he was interviewing young yet so this
reporter his name is Rocco Fuentes and
Paco Paco Fuentes versus you could
already tell the class difference yeah
he was interviewing him and so recently
a lot of the way Anya's his son he made
it he created a GoFundMe to get money to
fix his car or something and so when
Paco was asking Eduardo I like hey why
is your son over here making a GoFundMe
instead of asking his father for money
and that's when there's a lot a little
guy he was like why so like he had
already been asked this previously by
another reporter so it's like over and
over
yeah and it's kind of like that what do
you call it those smut news or those
like really low petty news like okay
yeah they talk only about super stupid
Goss to trying to find stupid dirt like
uh some TV shows those kind of questions
are kind of leading to the point where
is all your money are you [ __ ] broke
now that's hot dog yeah so then that's
when it was like well why don't you hit
him up
or why don't you go give him money if
you're so worried about him and then
that's when Paco was like well it's not
me I'm worried I'm just speaking for the
people that people want to know and then
it'll have I do want it although like
that's [ __ ] like they curate it
thank you they're like is that all
[ __ ] like they're just trying to
feed this information that people don't
even care about so then to make people
care so yeah he ends up saying like and
next time don't [ __ ] disrespect me
and then Paco was like I wasn't
disrespecting than he was but that's
them so everything's in Spanish oh I
love traditional culture I kept trying
to find something that what do you mean
traditional culture because after he
slapped that he wrote away to horse
[Laughter]
that's how they do it in Mexico you know
anything about your own culture I know
yeah this doesn't happen in America this
will happen in Asia this will happen in
Russia this will happen we talked about
but not hot he was more like a get away
cockroach yeah I want to see a man yeah
no he's different
I'm talking about us America for doing
this we don't know he didn't get in
trouble you're making it up in your head
isn't it a common trope of people of non
American let's say Latin America Asia
and Russia and maybe Eastern Europe are
a little bit more traditional meaning
they don't hesitate to smack a
[ __ ] if they get disrespected
and ghetto American culture yes and
don't [ __ ] twist my words are you
bother [ __ ] ghetto doesn't mean black
okay yeah that you be racist get meat
and Asians can't be ghetto why people
can't be I've met a lot of keto Asians
of mine and get away a lot of middle
class and above white people they do
lawsuits yeah true I don't think America
Americans never slap though we're not a
slapping ass country you know saying
other countries are they are these
slappers yes aggressive slap get the
[ __ ] out my face it's once pizza let me
correct your behavior yes
your mom and that slab I saw the way
your mom slapped you by that the way you
did your clap we slap like our parents I
miss those days you know I was never a
part of those days I just I'm just
saying when I see it in films I just
well let's see this white horse lat yeah
oh it's my mom yeah we Channel Acosta
come on go see no no problemo yeah can't
wait that's that's not a Will Smith slap
as you got it right welcome in sybiz
like this you might this eagle amen yeah
Will Smith slap whoo it's almost good
pee Jonas be Jonas like pigeons
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
community it's like how are they taking
it though so his side of the reporters
diet are like majorities on the reporter
side but they're saying like millennial
Beckett's millennial Mexicans changing
their ways I miss the days of Pancho
Villa he was a reason is because they're
saying that this reporter was just doing
his job
and like he was trying to start [ __ ]
with those question questions that
everyone else is asking already in the
media that they're just trying like the
whole celebrity gossip street gossip
industry it's all about getting like the
most gorgeous tiniest pettiest little
stories that people really don't give a
[ __ ] but it's just that we're really my
peaches and we want to know everything
so what you say about Mexican you say
we're petty to East LA college and I got
a little offended yeah dad how do you
say T how do you say Tina's been hey oh
no no like like sip tea a word yeah what
did you think it was
okay so they're trying to get the day oh
yeah out there yeah you wish my friends
know the tea means gossip yeah oh really
I didn't know that now that makes sense
to me what I just thought it was like a
really cute bike thing of him just
sipping is so stupid how many more dots
did he between two dots what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you all they've been on my
ass get off my [ __ ] ass thank you I
know else emo just so you know
Eduardo every time that he's in I'm no
guy like he's always portrayed as like
the hero like the the great guy like
always like yeah he's the guy on the
horse he broke ha ha no horse yeah I was
right I wasn't saying you were wrong so
he's like the leading man character yes
handsome guy like the Russell Crowe kind
of America son whoa so different looking
yeah it's the whole picture he tweet yet
is he tweeted this out back in like June
or July
he said funny how Anthony telenovelas my
dad always plays the hero but in real
life it's completely the opposite drug
addict abuses women oh yeah
so then a lot of the media now with this
whole bitch-slap thing they're pulling
this tweet back up and saying like oh
well you know now here's like more
evidence that he is well that's why he
has a GoFundMe could get a piece of [ __ ]
son that's good outing his dad it
doesn't matter what your dad does you
solve family problems with the family
first
you don't go put it out in public like
that [ __ ] and that's social media man
he's kids
go get that GoFundMe money [ __ ]
yeah so this is like a big ol thing
that's like clearly he does anger
problems obviously if he's like going
over here bitch-slapping reporter that
is not anger problems he did not beat
his ass a slap is a friendly gesture
it's a warning anyone could just go up
to you and bitch-slap you and that's a
friendly gesture ya know so honestly to
me a slap is like a toast
toast it's a handshake there's
intermediary actions that you take me
Bart if I know if I do something yeah so
if I do something to piss someone off
and they slap me I'm cool because to me
that's an inner mirror it's like it's
just like hey nice to meet you it's a
handshake it's a toast it's one of those
it's a pat on the back but when that the
slap turns into an actual punch in the
face that's different I think there's a
lot of gray area physical gestures it's
like a whole you know he being silly so
that's not so he to me he's just
exercising a toast
[Laughter]
exercising an introduction to a fight
that could have exactly you pull off
your gloves and you go I challenge you
to a duel now five o'clock we're gonna
have a gentlemen's duel that's what he's
doing so he has full management so he
gave you hurt my feelings
what do you think he did that guy a
warning cuz it wasn't anger magic he was
just [ __ ] wailed on after you slapped
them the guy said they did the
eye-to-eye right which usually means
like oh we're about to get down that guy
is a lot of locals gay like what are
gonna do now and the guys like no no
yeah I almost brought I almost feel like
I would rather be punched then slapped
in front of people like that cuz it felt
weird it's so disrespectful yeah like
you get to do what you want to do now
that one was hard you know that wasn't a
backhand though it was a front hand but
yeah it wasn't this way he did the
that's true she did it he did him when
you bend it that way maybe this way yeah
but when you bend it this way that's
that's a bear claw yeah yeah that's a
that's it your mind of a jackass hand if
you guys have time go look up this video
of this Russian lady arguing with the
cop videos you gotta pull it up I'm not
gonna even explain it it's one of the
best videos I've ever seen in my life
and I watch it sometimes when I'm
countin pull this one up I cried see
that's not anger management he has full
this guy he has full control over what
was going on I thank you David
I get it he didn't unleash his fury at
all I'm against any kind of violence and
I don't condone it but I can't deny that
it feels good that's why I like
countries that don't have long best
videos I've ever seen now watch I love
this [ __ ] the way he fixes glasses with
Olivia this will literally throw up like
17-game sighs Wade likes laughter - you
could tell it wasn't out of violence it
was like lady you're overreacting
yeah I'm gonna slap you back into
Rihanna and then her bangs kind of like
but she slapped there so fast and hard
she could even process this she would be
[Music]
continued on their merry way okay so now
how can I help you and then her sensor
came back to her that's right he could
what my ass that's why it's a toast to
another toast
yeah and it chilled everything else yeah
okay was it that the most interest thing
you've ever heard in your whole entire
life I don't even know what you guys
just talked about but anyways please
subscribe for more random videos more
funny content and more hahaha poopoo in
your pants stuff go ahead subscribe and
for more videos right there